pendant des années ils ont critiqué son
corps plus au cordeau l'âge disait-il
mais aujourd'hui après trois minutes
d'entraînement il est fin prêt à
affronter les plus grands boxeurs lors
d'un jeu vidéo par contre pas déconner
d'accord en pleine forme pour péter un
boxeur ses propos n'est sûr de soi un
fight on va prendre mon point on va le
mettre tout de suite dans la gueule des
adversaires alors avant tout la pesée
158 kg attendue du coup et je vais
affronter les titans
c'est pas juste en fait je fais 38 kg ha
ok on se trouve près du ring sa salle
d'entraînement mon gars mec c'est quoi
cette tête vont gars n'ont rien fait je
vous dirais le meilleur boxeur ou pas
alors tout me revient pas comme ça à mes
deux chiens au haut du corps
tétouan woerth c'est l'émoi d'une simple
enflammé auquel je dois choisir mon
adversaire depuis ce tableau est très
franchement voilà c'est pour ton bien on
va prendre des leçons avec lui à temps
et c'est le même mec que il ya deux ans
un rire tu m'attaques ans tom et tout
oui mais tu peux pas faire highway
allaitent les faits il m'a mis dans les
cordes
c'est quoi la tant que je n'ai pas
touché il croit que je veux pas qu'on
bat donc on va faire
l'infiltration on va passer sous lui et
on va te regarde
il fait bien celui-là mais on y apprend
comme ça c'est pour ton bien et on va
faire le falcon pelouse après falcon
punch c'est un sketch de ouf
on la démolit mec tu m'as appris
beaucoup de choses mon petit paulo et
hop la douche mes filles et mon con
c'est toi qui me l'a appris à longny
voir que billy joe
vraiment les il est vrai les mondial n'y
a pas inclus les assemblages troyen
hockey à l'état gardait nous salir
d'année ou au guichet ou tag est allé
tourner mon pote watanya degrés à fait
dans la moyenne
ok ok à terme et y créant des eaux des
lacs je m'étais coup d'envoi l'ailier
joe west était mon gars étaient prêts
dit sur moi j'suis fair-play mois moi je
sais pas mais fair-play pas non pas dans
ses mac ewen mouillage te connaître fait
attention à ton gaulle et ça c'est ton
froid pub la ja fut chef plus qu'à la
mort relève le produit non pas je peux
plus il m'a battu à temps c'est dire si
je puis me permettre à la salle tu
devrait muscler un peu les gens moi tu
vois tu auras du cuissot comme ça après
pas par surprise que tu appelles
question affaire fait du bruit elle
relève toi tu achetais d'être relevé ces
fonds au lait chaud mais juste ce qu'ils
veulent
n'importe quoi on préférait tout bio
boisé jeu steven chu ben badis au
chômage touche on va l'avoir
on va se concentrer ils sont la
puissance 0 trillard puissant requitter
m'envahit roquettes avec moi tu veux
rien faire
il est mort il est mort il est mort non
on a tué un diot je suis doit encore de
mon coach c'est quoi ce délire quoi du
coach que je sais que vous êtes un
parent dont il était fier de moi mais
quand même respecte un petit peu mon
intimité éloigne tourner deux mois est
loin de tournai je risque de me
transperce avec un truc pareil [ __ ]
ugly john à satan il est décédé
maintenant c'est louise félix a
bizarrement tous les mecs qu'on découpe
comme ça dans les films sont super
impressionnant mais ils vont démolir en
5 secondes
c'est parti on va lui casser les dents
je m'exposais je vais pas vous mentir là
j'ai une quotité de sueur qui est tombé
de mes bras assez alors à tort pouces
une seconde je suis un peu fatigué c'est
parti non non non rapide comme le faux
complots et oui ma maman elle mal du
monde à moi de ma vie te laisse pas
faire si ta détresse chez lucas du costa
rica au samedi - on n'est pas bien
comment gagner un combat clément au btc
rêver
mais que la vengeance pour avoir fait
sors tu mérites que je te met en sorte
ça marche pas tu vas mourir tu mentor du
menteur tu vas mourir c'est parti oh
[ __ ] arrête de mentir j'ai tout donné
ils seront là quoi [ __ ] il sonné l
affaire il faire gaffe il va être hyper
sauvage remake c'est une finale de
moscou c'est un combat à la fois de neuf
ans et demi qu'on attend d'elle tu ne me
parles pas à +2 à plus de cette distance
maintenant il est la plus bizarre quand
même un effet les petits des
attouchements sur ses poulains ou lin
qui je te rappelle sont extrêmement
doués un box non convoqués on y va allez
allez
c'est comme ça que commencer mais un
combat c'est comme ça c'est comme ça que
le duo mezzanine sert à quelque chose
aussi aller débattre larmes j'ai porté
une technique secrète à temps c'est un
passé petit nathan sharpe la technique
sont déstabiliser l'adversaire
ouais la technique du dos du ch
plongeurs pas cet été ça déstabilise a
longtemps pensé [ __ ] ça il s'est fait
refaire et est élu
a lens qu'on lève mais dis donc
elles sont sympas des combats le pilar
l'accident est pour mais sympathique web
et non non
là
non on aimerait arrête arrête de faire
ça mais on a encore non mais là je peux
plus la zep haider non mais là c'est
plus possible ses fistons tu peux y
arriver je me plais souviens toi de
toutes ces heures passées à s'entraîner
durement j'y arrive plus je sus gagnera
ce match parce que je suis dit j'y
arriverai pas moi qui gagne le match sur
à 10 millions de dollars aux caisses
parti soit il fait lui-même en attendant
on dit les doigts dans toi la map est
bon c'est pas du jeu légal imposé vous
n'avez pas greki sucer le sang de son
entraîneur non mais mec
ok on va faire ce qu'on veut c'est sympa
cette main gauche anti quoi bla bla bla
notamment après chaque page est collée
au corps tu prends un verre faire quoi
les cas ce qu on a gagné c'est vraiment
vampires mais attend et on leur prêtait
la jacques le guen peut pas se régler
elle propage que je vais le reconnaît
même technique ah ouais ouais tu aimes
ça tu aimes ça les coups dans la nuit à
bamako qui disent mon passage à huy at
war ce thème le fitheb bénin edouard aux
cherry hill sur la fin il se relève et
j'ai trouvé technique génial pour les
prendre corps est grand comme ça on
n'est pas à portée de ses longs bras et
il arrive à rien les affaires le combat
en plus vraiment terrible tu es beaucoup
j'ai apprécié on l ait rompu à et manu
chao c'est waouh
et il a l'intention d'en partir
à l'om l'aller victoire la médaille d'or
à jamais son rôle comme il faut essoukna
ce qui te fait main de ce n'est plus
l'affairé d'outreau soyez maccabi
turquie afin de prendre très cher à jean
dit on a prouvé ce ballet sans tricher
pour cette entrée dans une prochaine
tu as tout le monde paye